the first limited edition dual sense
controller our first hands-on with psvr
2 and more yakuza games than you can
shake a stick at all this on today's
gamespot news
alongside a new trailer for god of war
ragnarok during playstation's recent
state of play also came the reveal of a
branded dual sense controller featuring
an icy white and blue style inspired by
midgard along with images of a bear
kratos and a wolf atreus the story
trailer itself gives us our best look
yet at the plot of the game we get an
extensive narration from tyr the norse
god of war who crosses paths with kratos
and questions his greek counterparts
motivations the trailer shows off an
extensive breadth of different locales
as well as a bevy of new enemies the
developer having explained previously to
game informant at the studio was focused
on an increased variety of foes the
trailer ends with two incredible moments
we first get kratos and atreus standing
next to two large wolves staring up at
an eclipse i do want to point out
without proper eye protection remember
these are ancient gods so don't try this
at home spoilers for god of war 2018
atreus who was revealed to be loki at
the end of the game then shoots an arrow
at the moon one of the wolves chasing it
as it begins to move across the sky
tearing it as it goes this likely
indicates that the two wolves are skull
and hearty the sons of the wolf fenrir
whom himself is the son of loki yeah i'm
really interested to see how they
explain that in this game in the norse
myth skull and hearty are fated to chase
the sun and the moon to then catch them
in ragnarok plunging the world into
darkness so what we're seeing in this
trailer is potentially our first glimpse
of the game's take on the titular event
the final shot of the trailer is then
kratos squaring off against thor as the
former tosses the leviathan axe and the
latter throws the hammer mjolnir the two
colliding before their masters pulled
them back with magic toward their hands
metal god of war ragnarok releases on
november 9th but pre-orders for the new
duel sense begin september 27th in other
playstation hardware news gamespot went
hands on with psvr2 managing editor
tamor hussein says about the device
quote psvr 2 feels like an iteration on
the original which should come as no
surprise however what i learned from my
first experience is that these small
smart tweaks and additions are more
significant than they may seem at a time
when virtual reality feels like old news
psvr ii feels poised to be a shot in the
arm for it in the gaming space timur
played several games including sony's
own horizon call of the mountain his
full thoughts on which can be found in a
video here on gamespot's youtube as well
as a bigger deep dive article on
gamespot.com looking for more yakuza
games sega has you covered having
announced three in the last 24 hours
except they're not called yakuza games
anymore the series in the west to match
its name in japan will now be like a
dragon which was the subtitle to
yakuza's most recent spin-off in 2020
the first reveal that happened during
playstation's state of play was like a
dragon ishin that released in japan in
2014 on ps3 and ps4 it is being remade
from the ground up for the ps5 and tells
the story of how the iconic samurai era
vanished series protagonist kazuma
kiryu's likeness is being used for the
lead of the game sakamoto ryoma a few
hours later at the developer rgg studios
tgs presentation two more lego dragon
games were unveiled the first was like a
dragon 8 which reunites the series 7th
entry's protagonist ichiban kasuga with
yakuza 1 through 6 hero kyrie kazuma
coming in 2024. the second title
announced was like a dragon gaiden the
man who erased his name and will fill in
the gaps between yakuza 6 and leica
dragon 8 revealing what kazuma kiriu was
up to during that mysterious time the
game is reportedly half the length of a
main line like a dragon release and
comes out in 2023 and that is it for
today's gamespot news are you picking up
one of those god of war controllers
which leica dragon game are you most
excited for let us know in the comments
below and we'll see you here for more
news tomorrow on gamespot
[Music]
you